hey what's up you wonderful humans you
great gorgeous people you spectacularly
incredible group
of youtube rumble blaze tv viewers who
tune in each and every day to watch dave
rubin on the reuben report it's nice to
see ya
no you did not set your clocks wrong
know that there has not been an issue
with the rotation of the earth yes
we are live one hour early today it is
10 a.m eastern this is just a one-time
deal i've got to hop in my car the
second we're done here i've got a quick
event in miami beach and then i'm
heading over to the rumble offices
rumble just uh built out huge offices
over in sarasota which is the other
coast of florida and i've got a day of
meetings you know we're trying to save
the internet which thus
would save the fate of western society
and the world and the planet and the
whole thing so i have a busy two days we
just pre-taped tomorrow's q a which will
be back at our normal time of 11am
eastern we got three stories for you
today uh first a couple compilation
things happening over at the view you
know this show
barbara walters set this thing up about
25 years ago where is going to be
different women of different walks of
life of different generations different
histories different values where they'd
come together and talk about things
calmly remember that
that's a very different show than what
they've got going on now it's basically
whoopee and joy having mental breakdowns
every day with a rotating cast of other
lunatics and the whole thing should be
taped from a padded cell we've got some
video to prove that then the big story
yesterday of course was that uh joe
biden the man pretending to be president
uh he called fox news peter ducey a son
of a in an off off mic moment um i
think the world's gonna go on but i
thought we'd show you the clip and then
just get into a little bit of the
hypocrisy when a certain orange man once
called someone a son of a versus
when old joe biden did and then finally
because you know my policy on covet i'm
trying to only talk about kovid when
there's positive stuff to report well
believe it or not people something good
has happened in new york
a court in new york has actually
reversed
the
the mask not vaccine i almost said
vaccine the mask mandate in new york
small steps people small steps so those
are the stories for today oh and i just
want to say uh thank you for all the
comments yesterday you know i really
felt the first 20 minutes of the show
yesterday when i did this sort of
unpacking of what's going on with the
five remaining good liberals and the the
critique i would say not not attack
personal nor otherwise the critique of
barry weiss and bill maher
obviously it's something that hits very
close to home to me as someone that
considered myself liberal and has come
to see the weakness of liberalism and
and what's left
and i that was as
passionate as i run i think for the most
part you know i'm i'm pretty cool and
calm i think that's why you guys watch
the show but we got a ton of great
feedback comments emails people reaching
out in every which way possible uh and
i'm gonna keep talking about it and i'm
completely open as always to having
conversations with them about this and
really anyone that is willing to talk
about these things in a respectful
decent manner all right before we get to
all the stories i want to talk to you
guys about groov groove life hey ladies
and gents i'm pleased to welcome a new
sponsor to our show groovelife they've
got some of the coolest most unique
accessories for both men and women that
i've seen in a long time the groovelife
ring is the only breathable silicon ring
the grooves in the ring let air in and
moisture out it's so comfortable you
forget you're wearing it but that's not
all groove life makes their belts are
legit i'll be i'll be receiving my
groove belt life this week we thought it
was coming today but i think it's coming
tomorrow and i understand that it is
really the most comfortable belt known
to man this is a belt you never have to
adjust you just fit once and forget it
it's great for everyday carry and it's
perfect for the office the woods the
backyard and everything in between it
has the perfect amount of stretch to
give you the most comfortable all-day
fit ever and this belt has the world's
baddest buckle it snaps using
high-strength neodium
magnets for an easy seamless snap-on
snap off and has what they call stiff
tech that means no folding in your belt
loops groove life also has a mission
where we can get behind their goal is to
serve people inspire adventure and
reflect god in every aspect of their
business groove life has a 94 year no s
no bs warranty on every product they
sell cut it stretch it lose it break it
no problem groove life will replace it
right now get 10 percent off your
groovelife order at groovelife.com
with promo code reuben go to
groovelife.com ruben and use promo code
ruben for 10
off your groove life order
groovelife.com slash ruben promo code
reuben and i'm about to be all right
let's talk about the view a little bit
so again this is where the idea was that
we were going to have this diverse set
of women sitting at this big table and
they were going to be talking it out
and for many years especially while
barbara walters was there barbara
walters who was an actual journalist i
would say
an interviewer and a mainstay in sort of
mainstream american thought for decades
quite literally decades barbara
obviously stepped away from the show
it's probably about 10 years now that
she hasn't been on camera so can we get
the year that barbara walters stepped
away from the view but she was the
executive producer and the creator of
the show for many years she brought on
the other hosts they had a really nice
mix of things and you may remember years
ago on the view when they had elizabeth
elizabeth hasselbeck and she was a
really good conservative voice and she
would get into it with rosie o'donnell
who was a good liberal voice rosie has
subsequently sort of lost her mind
but there was real debate and
conversation on the show meredith vieira
was the moderator for many years i used
to watch it was a good program that was
doing a nice blend of politics and
culture barbara retired from the view in
2014. i don't think she has any
involvement anymore so about
eight years ago let's say uh anyway the
show has really devolved into sort of
woke leftist lunacy and people that i
really liked
whoopi goldberg joy behar i used to like
them they were sane liberals whoopi is
an incredible actress and great comedian
joy was a good comedian like
but they've just sort of lost their
minds so they played a clip yesterday on
the view actually going after bill maher
which is ironic considering what i was
doing yesterday and take a look
i don't want to live in your paranoid
world anymore your masked paranoid world
you know you go out it's silly now you
know you have your mask you have to have
a card you have to have a booster they
scan your head
like you're a
cashier and i'm a bunch of bananas
i'm not bananas you are
that's
not really funny to people who've lost
their kids
to this vaccine of people who've lost
family members or
dear friends to this it's it's just you
know listen nobody on the planet really
wants to go through this this is not
something we're doing because it's you
know sexually gratifying this is what
we're doing to protect our families and
you don't have to do it but stay away
from everybody because if you're the one
who's
not paying attention
and you're coughing and sneezing you
don't want to
then stay out of the public man this is
not nobody wants this
i don't want it and i think he's
forgetting that people are still at risk
who cannot get vaccinated people who
can't get little kids under the age of
five yeah what people with health
conditions how dare you be so flippant
man
how dare you be so crazy whoopi okay
there's so much there so first off she
misspoke when she said the thing about
vaccines killing kids unless she knows
something that i don't know but i'll
grant her that that was a misspeak now
ironically i guess i should start with
this related to everything the bill said
bill i agree with you which is why you
should not be voting for democrats right
that's what we talked about yesterday so
yes you get it bill uh but you should
probably be living in a place like
florida and fighting for freedom rather
living like in a place like los angeles
where you're subjected to all of this
nonsense but let's put that aside
everything that whoopi said there was
was complete insanity putting the the
misspeak uh aside the fear that she's
talking about and that young children
can't get vaccines and that there are
sick people
whoopi is sitting on a stage there at a
table with four or five other women who
are all masculist now i suspect and i
think we know this for a fact actually
uh that everyone in that building
despite the fact that you have to be
vaccinated to get into abc's building
right there they still have all those
people in masks so you've got an entire
audience of people in masks who already
are vaccinated and a group of hosts who
can sit there without a mask but then
during commercial breaks when the makeup
people come and the hair spray lady and
whatever they do to all of them to make
them look human during commercial breaks
they're wearing masks but the hosts
aren't women none of it makes any sense
but
if
you believe that somehow certain people
depending on their job can spread
and certain people can't in essence rich
people can't which is why rich people
can go into
restaurants and they don't have to wear
masks but the servers the waiters the
bartenders the busboys and the bell boys
they all have to wear masks i mean none
of it makes any sense
but that really
the inconsistency in the policy is sort
of a side rather than whoopi whoopee and
i really mean this whoopee we'll try to
get you this clip whoopi i'll you follow
me on twitter i'll dm you this clip
whoopee i think
beneath all of this nonsense you you are
a good person and what you're trying to
express there is that you're worried
about some people who might get sick now
i'm worried about some people who might
get sick too which is why i've always
said all along people should talk to
their doctor and figure out what's right
for them people should lose weight take
better care of themselves eat right
you should avoid people who are sick and
if you are sick you should take that
into account and perhaps not go to the
mall not go out to a big event but two
years after 15 days to flatten the curve
enough is enough it's time to be able to
go out and go to supermarkets and be
free and not wear masks on and why don't
you address the depression that kids are
facing and that teenage suicide
especially amongst girls is skyrocketing
and all of the social behaviors and the
social fabric that is fraying right now
is are you concerned about any of that
or do you think that if we're just all
vaccinated enough even though you're
vaccinated right now and you can still
get covert and still transmit covid do
you just think that if we all just keep
doing it keep doing it keep doing it
keep doing it and wrap our heads in all
of this stuff that no one will get
covered and will that make any of this
better will the human experience be any
better will our ability to flourish
be any better i don't think so whoopi uh
but whoopi is not the craziest person on
the view and i'm not even going to show
you a clip of joy behar here here's this
woman sarah haynes and she is fearful of
everything to the post-mask
part because i think there's a prudence
we've learned with the mass the hand
sanitizing that kind of like 911 with
flying is always going to be here now
there's a new normal in the beginning
when at post 911 people didn't want to
fly and the security measures felt like
uh how do we do this you know and now
it's the norm i think some of the things
we've learned in this pandemic are going
to stay the same i may never write a
subway again without a mask i may never
go indoors to big crowds and never feel
comfortable without a mask and that's up
to me to do that
yes lady it is up to you so you are
right about that part it is up to you if
you never want to go into a crowd again
if you never want to go into a store
again you never want to go to a baseball
game or the ballet that is up to you
what she talks about there though about
this new normal man do you see what
authoritarianism is so like something
really bad happens and thus we should
just break all of our senses and just
live a new way after that now we can
have a whole discussion about after 9 11
and you guys know i was in new york city
for 9 11. i am
it was intimately part of my life it was
part of everyone in america's life did
we do all the right things after well we
invaded iraq it was the wrong country so
we did that wasn't good did are all of
the policies that we did
the patriot act spying on our own
citizens now going to airports where you
have to take off your shoes and they and
are any of these people even qualified
for any of this go to the airport at jfk
if you think these people are qualified
to really be checking for bombs we also
know by the way and terrorist weapons
and the rest of it we also know by the
way that when they do their like annual
test where they just try to test to see
if they get things through tsa that they
get all sorts of crazy stuff through
anyway
but what she's really saying there is oh
bad things happen and then we should
just figure out a new way to live so you
should just wear masks forever and you
should just get injected forever and
everything else and it's like no how
about no how about the old way was
pretty good how about having privacy was
pretty good how about how you know
having a right to say this is the
decision i'm making for myself is pretty
good how about the right to say no just
because the government says something
doesn't mean it's the right thing but
these people they live in endless fear i
guess that really is what this is all
about more than anything else i refuse
to live in endless fear it does not mean
that i will make every decision
correctly right so i did not get
vaccinated i got covid i know plenty of
people that did get vaccinated and did
get covered covet did not affect me very
much it affected david a little bit more
michael got covid affected him a little
bit connor did not get covid we all
spent a lot of time together in a office
here in a studio here it's like everyone
takes the things their age what are you
doing to to take care of yourself oh
maybe i won't do this inside like you
can all do all of that stuff but if if
the driving force when you wake up in
the morning is fear you can see what it
does to society all of these videos that
we've all seen of the people screaming
at people for not wearing masks and
getting up in their faces which of
course you would never do if you
actually fear the backseat you'd be
running the other way it's like fear
cannot be the driving force behind a
society and and for whatever reason we
can go into all the reasons they may
want fear to be the driving force for
whatever reason they want it we cannot
let them win on that i refuse to let
them win on that and that's why
because i don't know that i've said
anything about the free state of florida
today
that's why florida is a great place the
people here are not dictated by fear
things are open and then just like sarah
haynes on the view said
if you want to wear a mask you can go
out and wear a mess but she's going to
wear her mask forever okay and by the
way some people will and i think it's
going to be a depressing amount of
people that will always be out in masks
forever and do you think they will be
fully actualized people who will live to
their fullest extent or will the fear
that they have of this thing 15 days to
flatten the curb will the fear that they
have of this thing actually seep into
every other part of their life
if fear is just like at the at the
top of the hierarchy in the way you
think about the world do you think you
can really get all the things you want
to get done in the world you think you
can really become who you're supposed to
be
or perhaps you have to say oh there is
fear and there is bad stuff and we're
going to reorder it a little bit and i'm
going to put other things above that
like freedom and like joy and happiness
and a whole bunch of other things
passion and desire etc i don't know
that's just me
let's move on joe biden is the man
pretending to be the president of the
united states someone is pulling his
strings obviously and occasionally they
wake him up and he gets out there and he
slurs over some words and says this that
the other thing but clearly is not in
charge and every now and again as you
know at the end of press conferences
they always say mr president i want to
ask you a question he said well they're
there i'm supposed to get going i'm
going to get in trouble for this
yesterday he gave a little press
conference and uh he mumbled something
that he thought was off camera but uh it
was not
will you take questions on inflation
then
thank you
[Music]
but but i thought we were supposed to
heal
i thought joe biden was going to be our
good grandfather i thought he was
supposed to be a nice man who was going
to bring the country together
after that scary orange med almost tore
us apart we almost became germany in
world war ii
but joe biden is none of those things
joe biden is as divisive as you can
possibly get joe biden actually has
policies that in many ways are ripping
this country apart joe biden has
demonized his enemies all along the way
he has demonized the unvacs he has
called most of us racist etc etc now i
don't care that he called peter ducey a
son of a people do these things
you know one of the problems that we
have right now is what we see on camera
is so disconnected from reality you see
these these awful people wearing masks
on camera but you know they're not
wearing masks on camera you you see them
telling you oh you have to uh you can't
go outside but we will go outside we're
going to go to parties like there's a
disconnect between the way they live
their life
and and what the public facing side of
this whole thing is so i don't really
mind that biden called ducey a son of a
i suspect he's called him worse
things and biden's been called worse
things and people say mean names and
sometimes i joke around and call people
names that's all good it's actually all
good it's completely fine and by the way
tension
between the president and the
president's administration and
journalists
that's good that's what you want you
don't want them constantly on their
knees showing him a good time but that's
usually what they do now the reason he
doesn't like peter ducey at fox news is
that peter ducey is basically the only
guy in the white house press corps
there's a couple news newsmax guys who
do it too but peter ducey is the main
guy sort of the standard bearer at the
moment for someone that is willing to
take the administration to test he's
actually doing real journalism as
opposed to what the rest of them do
which is oh joe you're so great how much
ice cream did you have yay you got out
of bed joe we love you joe
so anyway i don't really care about him
calling peter ducey a son of a and
by the way peter ducey doesn't really
care about joe biden calling him a son
of a here he is on hannity last
night we have some news tonight
uh after
years of clips of the president and i
kind of mixing it up on the campaign
trail and during the transition and here
at the white house
uh within about an hour of that exchange
he called my cell phone
and uh he said it's nothing personal pal
and we
went back and forth and we were talking
about uh
just kind of
moving moving forward and i made sure to
tell him that i'm always gonna try to
ask something
different than what everybody else is
asking and uh he said you've got to
and that's a quote from the president so
i'll keep doing it did he apologize
uh he cleared the air and i appreciated
it we had a nice call
he's that's not an answer did he
apologize that doesn't sound like an
apology he he said it's nothing personal
pal and i told him that i appreciated
him reaching out hey sean
uh the world is on the brink of like
world war three right now
with all this stuff going on i
appreciate that the president took a
couple minutes out this evening while he
was still at the desk to give me a call
and clearly at least he called you
powell but but you know what i i don't
need anybody to apologize to me uh he
can call me whatever he wants
so good for peter dc right it's like
he's taken it in stride i suppose it's
perfectly nice that biden called him and
said he said it's nothing personal which
is just kind of a funny thing after you
call someone a son of a if you're
calling someone a son of a you're
saying your mother is a female dog that
seems personal to me if you were like ah
you're an like that doesn't seem
personal it's just like eh whatever but
you're saying peter ducey your mother is
a female dog i'm a dog lover by the way
but so it's not really that offensive to
me
but it's just whatever you get the point
um so i think ducey's taking it in
stride which is which is actually the
right way to do it and i'm not sitting
here saying this is the most horrible
thing but i did want to show you one
other thing on this just to show you how
ridiculous in case you don't think that
these ridiculous people in the media are
ridiculous they are in fact ridiculous
here's brian stelter this is from the
defiant l's
twitter they do a great job of showing
you what these people used to say versus
what they say now uh so
here is stelter up top you're seeing his
tweet from uh march of 2018 when donald
trump was president and he called a
journalist the son of a that says
calling a journalist a son of a it
was wrong when trump
was just a candidate and it's even worse
now that he's potus and then he had a
link to a story about it he wrote about
it because trump called someone a son of
a here's what stelter said
yesterday about it when biden called
someone a son of a at the end of a
biden photo op when reporters when
reporters shouted questions hoping he'd
respond fox's peter ducey asked do you
think inflation is a political liability
in the midterms biden deadpanned it's a
great asset more inflation what a stupid
son of a
biden deadpan so that's his way of
saying biden's joking when he calls
someone a stupid son of a but when
donald trump does it we're gonna write
an article and it's worse than when he's
a candidate anyway you guys get it these
people are all frauds and ridiculous
people and everything else all right
guys we got one more story for you and
this is a good coveted story there is a
chance people are fighting back and
although i think that if you live in a
blue state you really should flee
although only if you're coming here to
vote the right way um i do think that
there are signs that not everything is
absolutely
apocalyptic
the new york mask mandate is going to be
reversed we've got a quote here from the
national review a new york state supreme
court judge on monday ruled that
governor kathy hochul's mask mandate for
schools and other public locations is
unconstitutional judge thomas rademaker
found that the governor and the state
health commissioner did not have the
authority to enact a mask mandate
without the state legislature given that
the governor no longer has emergency
powers the mask mandate has been in
place since mid-december when the state
saw a surge in the highly trans
transmissible omicron variant there can
be no question that every person in this
state wishes wants and prays that this
era of kovaden soon and that they will
surely do their part to see that it is
accomplished rademaker wrote in his
decision however enacting any laws to
this end is entrusted solely to the
state legislature while the intentions
of commissioner bassett and governor
hochul appear to be well aimed squarely
at doing what they believe is right to
protect the citizens of new york state
they must take their case to the state
legislature
that's a pretty clear explanation what's
going on here now i will add that at the
end there you're basically not impugning
their motives i've actually had it with
these people's motives i would say that
hochel who remember nobody voted for her
she was installed after they took out
cuomo nobody voted for her she has been
the worst sort of authoritarian so i
don't know what her motives are i do
think these people honestly get off on
ruining lives i think they get off on
the power of knowing that they can keep
people in masks that they can shut down
businesses i really do but let's put the
motives aside the the basis of the
decision there is that the governor is
not the king just because the governor
wants to do something you can't do it
this is what separation of powers is all
about the governor is supposed to be the
chief executive of the state the way the
president is the chief executive of the
country the president is not supposed to
make laws we have the legislature to
make laws right this is basic civics 101
i know you guys know all of this stuff
so the point is whether her intentions
are good or not she cannot just decide
you must wear masks to be in school you
must wear masks to be an employee of the
government etc etc so that shows you
that that beautiful system that we
created that no part of government was
going to get too much power that if you
if you chose to try to do something as
an executive that the legislature could
fight you on it and the judiciary would
decide what is legal it actually is
working even in as dysfunctional a place
as new york so there is hope and i will
keep finding the stories that give you
hope because i know not everyone can
live in florida i know it i know it
there is a lot of construction going on
here and a lot of people are coming here
and i should be sitting on the board of
florida tourism i'll talk to them about
that but the hope is that some of the
same people that remain in some of these
places can make sure they don't fully go
off the deep end
they they ain't going to be fixed at
least anytime soon because so much of
this has become cult-like and psychotic
uh i i would refer to you to segment one
about the view if you want more on that
however thankfully uh we've got some
good judges like rademaker up there in
new york and maybe some things will turn
around all right guys i've got a crazy
day i've got to drive all across florida
i'm going to ride an alligator all the
way to sarasota part one of my interview
with marco rubio it's my first interview
in florida we thought it would be best
with a senator from florida uh that's up
right now on youtube and of course the
full episode is up early and ad-free at
reubenreport.locals.com lots of good
stuff happening uh and i appreciate you
guys tuning in a little bit early today
uh we're pre-taping at 11 a.m for
tomorrow and then i'm back in studio
live on friday at 11 a.m oh no on
thursday at 11 a.m and then i'll be live
again on friday at 11 a.m so there you
go all right have a great day everybody
see ya